you
[Music]
what's an honor to have Peter stone with
us today for an MS Rai Distinguished
Lecture Peter is a Centennial professor
and associate chair of computer science
as well as chair of the robotics program
at the University of Texas at Austin he
did his PhD work at Carnegie Mellon and
he did his bachelors work at the
university University of Chicago in
mathematics I should say that the CMU
work was in computer science and after
that he went off to be a member of
technical staff at AT&T Labs for two or
three years
looks like three and before coming to UT
Austin his research interests include
planning machine learning multi-agent
systems robotics and e-commerce and he's
applied various principles of the
aforementioned areas to robot soccer
autonomous bidding agents and autonomous
traffic management peter has developed
teams of robots soccer agents that have
111 Robo soccer tournaments in both
simulation and win the real-world
version of that contest and he's also
been working on agents that have placed
in in winning roles in in ten oxygen
trading Asian competitions two tech
competition
peter is a Sloan fellow Guggenheim
Fellow Chipley I fellow I Triple E
fellow Triple A as fellow and a
Fulbright Scholar and I I've put some
pin through the list so it's shorter you
know but there's more there's more there
and in in 2013 he was awarded the UT
Austin University Texas System Regents
outstanding Teaching Award and inducted
into the UT Austin Academy of
distinguished teachers and will be
benefiting maybe a little bit of that
today in his lecture he also received
the itch Chi the the prestigious each
guy competed in thought award which goes
to a leading AI researcher in the
thirty-five just up just a couple a few
years ago and the autonomous agents
research award
a little bit before that he's also a
renowned in being the chair of the
Standing Committee of the 100 year study
on AI and that's a quite a distinguished
role as well so with that Peter all
right
thanks Eric for the for the very kind
introduction and and yeah it's been a
been a real pleasure and honor working
working with with Eric on the on the 100
year study of artificial intelligence
and we are at an interesting moment now
where we're trying to think about what
the second the second study will look
like we got it got a lot great reception
from the from the first one and as light
as Eric likes to say you know this is a
longitudinal study the one one point
doesn't make a line but two points do
make a line and so there's a lot of
pressure on what the second one will
look like to to really sort of yet get
this going so spending a lot of time
thinking about that so but yeah thanks
for thanks for the for inviting me to be
here it's a real honor and thanks all of
you for coming in to talk like this I
often have to make a choice is you know
there's a bunch of different things that
I do in my lab and so you know I could
give sort of a pick a single topic and
go deeply and talk just about that or I
could give sort of a you know a broad
and shallow overview of lots of
different things I'm gonna try to sort
of you know skirt the the difference
between those two and and give you an
overview of what I focus on in my lab in
general but then also take a couple of
deep dives on to technical contributions
that we've made recently some of which
were led by people who are sitting
sitting in this room happened to be here
at Microsoft now and those are gonna
focus on efficient robot skill learning
so first of the you know sort of the
overview I've been been the talks that
I've given almost four that I would
realized recently I can say for the last
quarter century have
almost many of them have had this this
research question the sort of a theme
that's driven my research over over that
long period of time and it's to what
degree can autonomous intelligent agents
learn in the presence of teammates and
our adversaries in real-time dynamic
domains
that's sort of what unifies all the
different things we do in my lab that
leads us to publish in in various
different areas the autonomous agents
and multi-agent systems conferences
robotics as well some autonomous agents
are robots though not all are and then
within machine learning especially to
focus on on reinforcement learning and I
mean they're going to really look at the
the interplay between reinforcement
learning and robotics in this talk we do
in in my lab sort of work from both ends
of the of the problem we've there's work
that sort of starts from the algorithms
and the theory and sort of you know but
I call sort of bottom-up research
towards applications and we also work
sort of from the other end from some
motivating applications and and give
more top-down try to think about what
what kind of research needs are there
that we don't yet have within our within
our arsenal within within AI and and to
use that as sort of a pulling function
and if I'm gonna give a one slide
overview it's it's hard to give the
details of the you know the algorithms
in theory but I can very quickly give
you an overview of some of the
motivating application domains that I've
worked on over the years and and those
include as Eric said in the introduction
robot soccer this is a clip from a
competition about almost 15 years ago
now where are these robots made by Sony
the Sony I bows were were working
autonomously trying trying to score a
goal when Sony stopped making those
those robots the the standard platform
the hook to these humanoid robots the
nows that are now made by Softbank our
robots are the ones that
with their hands behind their back and
this was the finals of the 2012
competition in Mexico City we were
playing against a team from the
University of Bremen the prior year
champions and you have to remember with
this you're looking at this thing robots
are fully autonomous their sense the
sensing deciding and acting here's our
robot going in on a breakaway little bit
slowly but but it this was the you'll
see it go up and calmly make the ball
off of the off of the goalposts into the
into the goal so that was on that was on
our way to a to a 4-2 victory and when
we got back to Austin they lit the tower
orange for us which they usually only do
when the football team wins so we were
very very honoured by that I'll talk a
little bit I'll talk a lot more about
RoboCup on the on the next slide I just
became the president of the the robot
Soccer Federation I'll talk so I'll talk
a little bit about that but we also work
in social robotics in robot service
robots this is a video from a joint work
with my colleague ray Mooney on grounded
language learning for robots so this is
a video that was illustrating a study
that we did where we have these rope the
robots like this sort of wandering our
hall more often than not we I tell
people you don't have to ask us for a
demo you just come to our wing and
they'll be this robot wandering around
in this particular case it was over a
week-long study learning the way people
would ask for for leading and delivery
tasks and we were able to show that over
the over the course of the week that
that it was that it got the dialogues
got shorter people were reporting that
they were less frustrated with the
interactions and and it was more
successful at completing the tasks that
that people that people wanted to do I
also had a I did have a car in the DARPA
urban challenge back in 2007 so this is
our car in the in the in the back that's
waiting to make a left hand turn all the
other cars working on the inside were
driven by human drivers with with
helmets on looking a little bit scared
but we didn't run into them so our car
made it had to you'll find a gap in
traffic make a left turn it did that
about eight loops in 20 minutes
we don't have that autonomous car
anymore we we retired tire did all the
car companies are really you know
investing a lot of money in autonomous
cars now but we do still think about
what the world will look like when all
the cars on the road are autonomous will
we still need traffic signals and stop
signs or can we using multi-agent
systems have something that looks more
like this what's going on here is the
cars that are white this is a simulation
of course the cars that are white have
called ahead for a reservation instead
of you know dealing with red lights and
green lights there they have a
reservation for the space-time that
they'll go through the intersection the
ones that are yellow don't have a
reservation yet but once they turn white
they have a guaranteed path through the
intersection that won't they won't
collide with any of the other cars one
of the one of the first times I showed
this was was about 12 or 13 years ago at
a talk I was giving you the India and
somebody said oh all the intersections
look like this but but the difference
here is that we can we can guarantee
that that as long as the cars are
following the protocol there won't be
won't be any accident so and this has
led to again a decade and a half or so
of research on how can we make traffic
flow through intersections and city
grids more efficient without necessarily
building building more roads and that
that also could be the subject of a of a
full talk and so these are the kinds of
applications that motivate the research
that I do in my lab that I'm going to
talk about in the sort of technical deep
dives but also I should say that that I
have a you know sort of we got to the
point where we feel like reinforcement
learning is ready for prime time for
industrial usage and so I formed a
company called Co jatai I'm the
president and CEO Oh oops I think I
might be yeah beginning founded the
company with with satinder Singh and
mark ring and there's a illustrious
brain trust we call it that they've sort
of been colleagues working on
reinforcement learning with us over the
over the years and just a few months ago
we launched a continue a SAS platform
that's designed for not for people who
who want to do research on reinforcement
learning so
maybe probably not the target audience
of people in this room so much as much
as people who want to use reinforcement
learning in an industrial setting and so
maybe me oh maybe some of you don't want
to necessarily get into reinforcement
learning research but have a problem
where reinforcement learning would apply
this is now available for for for you so
you can get a forty day free trial you
can you know and then we've got some of
the first markets here in automotive and
robotics control and semiconductor
control but really we feel like the use
cases for reinforcement learning are
endless but most of the platforms that
are out there are sort of designed for
researchers and this is you know so
we've put all of our effort into sort of
making this scalable and easy to use for
for people who want to to apply
reinforcement learning and and the long
term objective you know there's lots of
platforms for supervised learning we see
reinforcement learning is sort of the
stepping stone towards towards the the
ultimate objective of continual learning
being able to to learn multiple
different tasks from one another and the
sort of transfer learning kinds of
setting in one sort of long ongoing
existence just like we do is as people
so I'll be happy that I'm not going to
talk so much about coach Atty in this
talk but I'll be happy more than happy
to talk with anybody offline if you're
interested and of course you know you
can get information on our on our
website so you know that's sort of the
the overview of the kinds of things we I
work on and some of the motivation I'm
gonna I'm gonna spend just one more I'm
gonna go a little bit more detail into
robocop the robot Soccer World Cup
because that's really the the motivation
for the for the efficient robot skill
learning that I'm gonna talk about and
then I'm gonna do like I say sort of two
more deep dives on technical aspects one
in the space of sim to real so learning
and simulation getting that to apply on
a real robot we introduced a new
algorithm known as grounded simulation
learning and then I'm also going to talk
about imitation learning from from
observation and in particular two
different algorithms that we've
introduced recently one based on
behavioral cloning and one based on
inverse reinforcement so to start with
the motivation I said you know I've
shown you
clips from from Robocop I am about to be
IRA I am now the president of the the
RoboCup Federation which includes people
from around the world who all are bound
by an ambitious long term goal which is
to create a team of human humanoid
robots that can beat the World Cup
champions on a real soccer field by the
year 2050 it's good to have goals we
know long you know who knows people ask
me if it'll be possible or not you know
30 years is a long time we learned a
long time ago in AI that if you're gonna
make it you know in a prediction like
this best to put a year on it that's
after you're likely to have retired
because then you know no one will hold
you to it
but but it's you know it's it's been
going on now for for many years we just
had the 23rd Robocop I believe and
there's several different leagues it's
got many virtues as a challenge problem
very different from sort of you know
having the physical interaction makes it
very different from some of the games
like chess and go and jeopardy and
things like that there's there are
different leagues the but the best way
to see some of the progress is to see
what it looked like starting back in in
the early years the first Robocop tour
in 1997 in 1998
these are different leagues up in the
top left the standard platform League
those are the early Sony AIBO robots and
and these are videos from teams that
were created by people you know from
from around the world not all my own
robots the middle-sized robots up here
we're using a real soccer ball and you
know there was some some goals scored
even though there wasn't much resistance
from goaltender's all all that often um
there this the beginning of the
simulation league the small size league
the back in 90s everything sort of
frustrating to watch right now and you
know I'm gonna look at it but you have
to remember back in 1997 a lot of robot
assists you know didn't really have
robots right they worked on an aspect of
the problem said this could apply to
robots getting you know 30 robots in a
room that um only caught on fire
occasionally was a big it was a big win
back in that time if you now jump ahead
ten years but still you know quite some
time in the past 2005-2006 you can see a
lot of improvements there's you know the
robots are moving more quickly they're
better individually they're they're
starting to be teamwork
it was the
beginning of the humanoid League so they
just did a penalty shot competition that
year but now there's there's games with
these humanoid robots and you know there
were attempted saves the and you know
again the thing to remember here is that
all of these are fully are fully
autonomous one of the leagues that we've
been most successful in is the is the 3d
simulation League and in fact Patrick
mcalpine is now now here in the audience
has been really the driving force behind
that I think we just won for the eighth
time in nine years this is a some
highlights from a couple of years ago
but this gives you a sense of what the
3d simulation league looks like each of
the each of the agents is controlled by
a separate process so unlike a video
game where you could have one program
controlling all of them they have
partial information and we've used a
several different techniques but but I
this is Patrick's favorite highlight so
I always promise him I'll show show this
one it wasn't on purpose but you know
the the robot managed to kick it through
the legs of the opponents and and into
the goal but they used the hierarchical
machine learning method here to learn
skills that have been turned out to be
more robust than the other team that
walking and kicking and things like that
and also some multi agent methods to
figure out where the robots should
should position themselves so this will
this will come back into into the next
segment of the talk as well but again
you know the challenges there are
immense in that and you know just
getting the robots it's in the physics
simulator so just getting them to be
able to stand up without falling over is
itself a challenge and again we could
give I could give a whole talk on the
the research that's gone into that and
that that was really the the centerpiece
of Patrick's dissertation I did say the
goal is by the year 2050 to have a team
of humanoid robots that can beat the
best World Cup champions on the real
soccer field
we don't play against the World Cup
champions but the the champions of the
middle-sized League here often
play against myself and some colleagues
so this is from 2011 world and the
people make the robots always say oh
they're gonna hurt you that's pity oh
they're way too fast for you but then we
show that the aging aging-- amateur
soccer players are still able to to pass
the ball around the robots that goal
didn't count because I was called for
offsides but in the you know in
principle you can see that we're still
faster than the faster than the the
robots able you know better is better
low-level skills but every year it does
get a little bit harder some people you
know we say this because we're getting
older not because the robots are getting
better but I actually think it's a
little bit of both so and we just did
that again and actually when I look at
this now we just you know we just have
the 2019 competition and definitely the
robots are a lot faster and more capable
now than they were you know even even
just a few years ago in that video I
should also I want to emphasize that
Robocop is not just about soccer it's
also there's there's a Robocop rescue
for disaster rescue scenarios and
there's also we participate in my lab in
Robocop at home which is similarly for
robotics multi-agent systems AI but now
in a service robot capacity and there's
there's a few different leagues there
including a standard platform League
where everybody uses this Toyota HSR
robot and the robot has to do tasks like
putting away groceries on shelves and
and and interacting with people setting
the table this this is a clip from a
taking out the trash the robot has to go
to a trash can take off the lid pick up
the pick up the garbage it's it's over a
five minute trial it has to actually
pick up two different garbage bags to
take them to a deposit location so I'm
not going to show the show the whole
video but these are the kinds of tasks
that we have the have the robot doing so
this is where the it gets to you know
the second bag and then navigates to the
to the end there but there's you know a
lot of human robot interaction kinds of
challenges that come up in this in this
event and mode including one of the
tasks is is a restaurant task where the
robots taken to
a restaurant that it's never been in
before so it hasn't mapped where there's
real customers is then people have to
tell it orders and it has to go up to a
table identify what was ordered pick
them up bring them to the person these
are the kinds of challenges that and
it's this is very very difficult it
motivates the kind of reasoning that we
just presented at a at the I caps
conference my PhD student Yuchun John is
shown here interacting with the robot in
an open open world reasoning kind of
scenario so where the she's talking with
the robot about trying to bring fruit
from the from the kitchen
okay now the point of this video is that
the she said that she wants an apple but
the robot doesn't know for sure this is
open-world reasoning so it doesn't know
for sure if there is an apple in the
kitchen and so we're gonna have sort of
two different endings to this to this
video one in which it searches for the
for the Apple I'll speed it up a little
bit
searches for the Apple on the the the
locations in the kitchen where there the
Apple maybe and doesn't find an apple
there so it then goes to the next place
here at in this version of the video it
finds the Apple and and now it basically
has to do a step of sort of merging the
the hypothetical Apple that had you know
that it had had an its knowledge base
with the actual instance of the Apple
and then taking it back to to you Chen
and see we can still have some there's
plenty of work that can be done on the
human robot interface as you'll see here
but in the alternate version of the
world here where the there wasn't even
an apple
it then goes and looks again for other
places where it might be but then it's
you know it's it keeps the the Apple in
this knowledgebase as being hypothetical
and when it doesn't find one it has to
go back and report that to the person
and even this is even a little more
awkward but you'll hear what the what
the robot says so we'll work on the
actual language but the the point here
was the was the reasoning and the
ability to you know for the robot to be
able to to deal with with you know
multiple different actual worlds and
keep the key to this was keeping some
objects as being hypothetical as opposed
to being instantiated fully in the in
the knowledge base okay
so that's those are the kinds of things
that that motivate a lot of the work
that we do in my lab the robot soccer
challenged the RoboCup at home challenge
one of the things you have to do if
you're if you're going to be able to
succeed at these is to have low-level
skills for these robots and so here's
where I'm gonna go into a little bit of
more technical detail on how we've
achieved that first in a sim to real
context and this is joint work with both
Patrick who's who's here and Josiah
Hannah a PhD student of mine who's about
to graduate and is going to start a
faculty position at University of
Wisconsin and the the idea is the
motivation here is that learning on
physical robots is not very data
efficient it requires supervision
especially if you're trying to get them
to walk they can fall over they could
break and and so it's you know it's very
tempting to say well let's build a good
simulator and just learn in simulation
and make that work on the on the real
robots but you know you learn very
quickly if you've if you've done this
people have tried this for years that
you know you can you can learn in
simulation a very robust walk like this
one this is some one of our learning
trials from early years where we were
having
robot tried to learn as well as possible
to kick your to walk fast while
dribbling a soccer ball if we take that
walk skill and put it into the real
world it's it's can execute so you can
actually take those same commands and
execute them on the robot but after two
steps it falls over right it's not a
good policy it's it's a executable
policy but not a good policy to see sort
of in in slow motion here you know it
takes a couple steps and then it looks
like it's tripping over the line but the
line is actually flat so so you know so
the question here is how can we and
there's been a bunch of research on this
problem of sim toril so we're not the
first of course to think about how can
we bring these to bridge this reality
gap the gap between simulation and
reality there's there's two sort of
classes of approach one is to to try to
learn a robust policy to make your
simulator more noisy right to make it as
so that so that whatever policy you
learn is likely to to work even in
environments that are not the same as
the simulator and so there's sort of a
class of approaches that try to do that
and and then there's another class that
that tries to to make the simulator more
like the real world based on data from
the real world and try to you know to
get the simulator to really align with
the real world and and the approach I'm
going to talk about falls within that
second class but with the crucial
difference is that most people are doing
that trying to make a perfect simulator
and we start this research with the with
the idea and the acceptance that that's
never gonna happen there's always going
to be a reality gap instead we're just
gonna try to make the the simulator
closer to the real world
'inna protect the particular paced place
in policy space where we're currently
searching and so the the basic paradigm
is going to be an iterative process
where we take a real world policy
execution and then some state action
trajectories use that to ground the
simulator and I'll tell you exactly how
we do that in a second take that
grounded simulator and then do policy
improvement in simulation and then
repeat that gives us an improved policy
that we can then execute in the real
world we can then reground the simulator
and and
keep going so the crucial question here
is how do we ground the the simulator
and oh I should have said two slides
back I should have mentioned that you
know in on in in general you can you
know it's not that hard to build a
simulator that has the same format of
policy takes the same actions out it has
the same sort of states and and rewards
the thing that's very difficult is to
make it so that the transitions that the
state and you know the state transitions
and the reward function for the action
that you give are the same they're
typically very different that's what
makes the simulator different from from
reality so the so you know in some sense
what we want to do is to alter the
simulated environments so that it's that
it's closer to the real world and in
fact we're gonna do that by in a black
box kind of a way one way with without
opening the simulator at all by just
placing a wrapper around the actions
that get sent from the from the policy
to the simulated environment with the
goal that if an action was sent we want
to change it to an action such that it
has the same effect in the state and
reward space in the simulated
environment as the original action would
have had in the real environment okay so
that's that that's the grounding and I'm
gonna tell you exactly how we do that
we're gonna so we replace an action
every action that comes out of the
policy with an action that produces a
more realistic transition so we're in
effect learning this function G shown
here and actually I'm gonna tear that
open that up into two separate functions
one's a forward model of the simulator
that says given the state I'm in and the
action that I just took what's the next
state that I'm gonna get to so that's a
that's a forwards dynamics model of the
real world and then there's a inverse
dynamics model of the simulator that
says if I'm in a particular state s T
and I want to get to the next state s
hat what's the action I would need to
take to cause that transition that's an
inverse dynamics model of the of the
simulator so you can think of that just
in one dimension if we take this you
know my elbow is the joint that's being
controlled it might be that in the real
world if I tell it to move to ninety
degrees in one time step it doesn't get
there
right
only gets maybe you know a third of the
way but in the simulator it goes maybe
two-thirds of the way let's say because
the simulator has a you know doesn't
have the slower reaction time well then
the forwards dynamics model will say
that from 180 degrees if I tell it to go
to 90 degrees it will actually you know
move to you know I guess what would it
be 1 100 145 degrees or something like
that and then and then we say well
what's the command that I would have to
give in the simulator from 180 degrees
to get to 145 degrees that's the inverse
dynamics model so that's in one joint
now we want to do this for the the whole
for all of the the joints in the robot
and so and then once you do that we have
basically a grounding in action
transformation that works at this the
current point in policy space that we're
operating like the current point in
pulses policy space because this
forwards dynamics model is based on
real-world trajectories from the current
policy that we're executing and so we we
learn both the forwards model and the
inverse dynamics model but from a
relatively small number of real-world
trajectories so 2,000 times steps each
and 15 of these gives us a whole bunch
of transitions of here's the state I was
in with all my joints here's the action
that I was given and here's what
actually happened to the joints and then
similarly in this in the in the
simulator we can get an inverse model
saying here's a state I was in here's
the next state I was in and here's the
action that got me there we learned it
with a with a multi-layered neural
network that takes you know state in
action from the real world in gets a
predicted next state which we can get
labels from these trajectories and then
takes this state and predicted next
state and tries to get the action that
would cause that to happen and and then
we can so that's the basic method we can
then evaluate it in in a number of
different ways we have our real robot
and then we have two different
simulators so yeah
no that's right so I'm gonna show you
that so we started to our initial policy
here it was the state of the art fastest
walk that anybody been able to get to
work on this robot and it was developed
by some folks at the University of New
South Wales and and we're I mean the
show that we that we improved from there
so yeah it's not a learning to walk from
scratch from flailing it's starting from
a walk and can we improve it that's a
good that's an important point so we had
two different simulators sort of a lower
fidelity simulator a more physically
realistic simulator and then the real
robot so we can do you know sort of
three different kinds of experiments the
main one is going from this simulator to
the real world but then you know in
controlled experiments we can go from
simulator - hi - ility simulator to get
more more data and and and so that we do
in the paper the policy search algorithm
that we use is a is the CMA yes so
that's the the learning algorithm that's
that's being used in simulation it's a
derivative free stochastic search method
and and then yeah to answer the question
here's the initial policy so this is
this is the robot the walk developed by
the University of New South Wales it was
the fastest walk at the time and it I
was able to go about nineteen point
three centimeters per second
and and then if we went we grounded the
simulator based on the the data we took
from that from that walk and then did
learning and and ended up with a walk
after one iteration that was
significantly faster this is twenty six
point three centimeters per second you
see it's sort of learning to be a little
bit more squat to the ground then we
repeated and reground in the simulator
with data from that walk and ended up
with what is I believe still the fastest
stable walk on these on these robots at
28 centimeters per second so that's and
we know this was done on this this
single this single task
Josiah's PhD thesis sort of uses this as
the central motivator and is now getting
trying to trying it on we have had some
success on another task on the same
robot we're now trying on a completely
different cinder real task a process
control
for in oil refineries and and it's also
opens up some some interesting
theoretical questions empirical
questions when does this kind of
approach work and when it is it not but
there's also some really interesting
connections to off policy evaluation in
reinforcement learning and safe learning
and these are the main sort of
theoretical contributions of Josiah's
dissertation which he's going to be
defending in about two or three weeks so
that's sort of you know the yeah yeah so
that's I mean that's a good question as
well there's a lot of research on
changing the reward function shaping
rewards and there's you know sort of
theory about how can you change the
reward function such that you won't
change the optimal policy so I'd say
that that's you know sort of that's
related to this in this in this work
we're focusing on the the transition
function the reward function is usually
easier to to align between simulation
and reality right I mean in both cases
it's the speed of the robot that's
measurable there's not really a
difference there the thing that's really
hard to ground and align between them is
you know what will happen when the you
you know execute oh you issue a torque
command and the foot is hitting the
ground and there's friction and that
transition function is the thing that
the people put a lot of effort into
trying to get right and that we
basically say look we're never gonna get
that right there's always going to be a
gap let's just try to you know to and
it's important to note that this
grounding function might make the
simulation incorrect more incorrect in
other parts of the search space it just
we just want it to be sort of in the the
region where we're searching we want to
make sure that it's that it's better but
yeah it's a good question
problems in Korea like light our radar
you know the eldest lady home super
digging liking the second order effects
upgrade our super car yeah principal I
mean if you have a simulator that and
you can measure the the differences
between what's happening in the real
world and happening in the simulator
then this general idea you could you
could lift up and apply you could say
you know what happened in the real world
what would I need to do in the simulator
to make it more like the real world
effect in the perception and then let's
use our learning algorithm in the
simulator in that sort of grounded raft
simulator so yeah and we haven't tried
anything like that but but in principle
yeah I'd be really interested in seeing
if there's especially if there's a use
case for that or like a situation where
that's that's particularly needed and
the difficulty is at that at that
perceptual modeling then it would be
yeah be really really interested yeah
it's a great question we really read
just at the beginning points of
answering that question we have we have
now two examples of this you know this
is our best example the one that we got
working first we have another example of
a sort of a motion task on this same
robot where like I say we're trying it
in this third task and now we're
starting to ask questions of like you
know what properties of the simulation
need to be you know need to hold for it
to to be applicable and to work but but
really we're not far enough along to be
able to for me to give you any any real
insight into that yet I think it's you
know it's it really early stages for
exploring the you know what are the what
are the limitations of this but we have
a really nice success story to launch
from good let me move on to the second
now is the second sort of technical dive
deep dive a little bit and it it
actually has two parts and this is a
this is the PhD thesis work of Faraz to
Robbie who's sitting here as well and
doing an internship here this summer and
it's in the area of imitation learning
from observation I'm going to introduce
a model-based approach that we call
behave
real cloning from observation and a
model free approach which is generative
adversarial inverse imitation from
observation and and this is joint work
with Fras and also Garrett Warren L
who's a research scientist at army
research lab so so imitation learning in
general the goal is to learn how to make
decisions by trying to imitate another
agent it's another a very appealing way
to try to learn skills on a robot
especially if you have examples of what
you want them to do so
conventional imitation learning involves
having observations of other agents
demonstrations consisting of state
action pairs so for instance this is the
work of Scott Neko and where he has a
person sort of guiding the robot saying
here's what I want you to do and so the
robots were and while he's doing that
the robot is recording the state that
its joints was in and what actions that
were taken what you know where did it
move next but the challenge of this is
it precludes using a large amount of
demonstration data where the action
sequences aren't given like YouTube
videos right there you see what happens
but you don't know what actions were
taking and and so there's you know there
are a bunch of for conventional
imitation learning there there's two
general classes of algorithms there's
behavioral cloning which is basically
you you take the sequences of these
demonstrations and try to learn a
function directly from when I was in
this state what action was taken that's
a supervised learning problem for every
state that you were in what action was
taken you can learn that then you can
try to imitate that and the other class
of problems is it is known as inverse
reinforcement learning where you take
the demonstrations try to
reverse-engineer what's the reward
function that the demonstrations are
trying to maximize and then use
reinforcement learning to try to
maximize that same reward function and
there have been successes in both of
these prone approaches assuming that you
have access to the actions not just the
state sequences but the actions as well
and but in biology it is possible
definitely to learn without access to
those sequences as is very apparent from
this video which I've you know I've
always assumed when I watch this video
that it's
that the the bird is imitating the
people just by observation although
people now pointed out to me there might
be the people are imitating the bird I
don't know but either way some organism
is imitating another organism without
access to the actual actions right just
by observation and so that's the goal
here of imitation from observation it's
how to perform it learning how to
perform a task given state only
demonstrations so the demonstration will
be a sequence of States you want to
learn a policy from States to actions
and again we're not the first to try to
try to address this this challenge there
has been work on from other other labs
on trying to do this but with
limitations first they've concentrated
mostly on the the perception problem of
trying to - from the states sequence try
to figure out what actions were taken
and or you know try to try to figure out
what the states were that the agent went
through and then and rather than
focusing on what actions can we take to
try to be as close to the to the
demonstrations as possible and also they
mostly have required time aligned
demonstrations so meaning that if you
have multiple demonstrations that you
get to the same state at the same time
which is actually very inconvenient for
cyclical actions like walking right
where you can get to the same state
multiple times and you might have
demonstrations where the walking happens
more quickly or more slowly you want to
be able to to you know to learn from
those kinds of demonstrations as well so
so our two approaches the model-based
one first is is called behavioral
cloning from observation it and the
difference between conventional
imitation learning and behavioral
cloning is that rather than having a
demonstration that looks like this with
States and actions it's got just States
the states it doesn't know the actions
and it takes a model-based approach
which is learning an inverse dynamics
model to try to fill in what those
actions were trying to infer the actions
and then use a conventional behavioral
cloning method so that's a you know you
can imagine how that would work the
diagram here is you initialize your
policy run it collect a bunch of data to
learn what happens when you're in a
state and take a you know taking action
what next state you get to you can then
learn this inverse dynamics model from
state and next state
what action must have happened and then
once you have that given your state only
demonstrations you can use that to fill
in the missing actions and then update
your policy using behavioral cloning and
so that's the that's the sort of you
know the high-level view of the
algorithm and and this can be applied
you know we've applied it in sort of
these majokoi domains like this ant that
has to has to run forwards
it's a 111 dimensional state space in
eight dimensional action space and and
we can compare it here to two existing
methods where the dashed line is random
behavior in the simulator the we've
normalized the expert demonstrations to
have a performance of 1.0 and then we're
going to compare against a bunch of
different algorithms not just on forward
speed it's a four dimensional task
including magnitude of the of the the
control actions so actually one of these
feature the feature encoding method
actually feature a feature expectation
matching method ends up back doing it
very poorly on this past task it's known
to not do well so it gets negative
reward on this but the other sort of
state-of-the-art methods gale generative
adversarial imitation learning and and
behavioral cloning which do have access
to the actions I have this performance
and in our method I'm sorry then
behavioral cloning that's the red is
doing quite well
behavioral cloning from observation our
method in green is doing competitively
with these with these even without
access to the to the actions and so that
was sort of the first the first sort of
promising result and then we started
asking well what happens if we do give
some kind of interaction to the an
experience to the method so in this case
the inverse dynamics model is learned
using a random policy taking is you know
sort of analogous to what we did in
grounded simulation learning you can
imagine doing this you know in a more
iterative fashion and so we can update
the model with the learned policy and
then use a parameter alpha to control
the trade-off between how many
interactions you get and and and the
performance so the so when alpha equals
zero that's the exact method
I already showed you it's just
behavioral cloning from observation from
the random policy and as we increase
alpha we're increasing the number of
interactions allowed at each iteration
so you know the main the only difference
between the previous method is that we
basically close the loop here that that
we once we've updated the policy we then
rerun that policy and and learn the
inverse dynamics model again and just
sort of diagrammatically all the
previous methods basically do all of
them get all of their environment
interactions after the demonstration and
can be very expensive post a
demonstration the method I already
introduced on the top gets a whole bunch
of data before the demonstration to
build it's inverse dynamics model but
then doesn't need any more interactions
by adding this alpha parameter we're now
sort of bridging the you know sort of
bridging the gap between these two are
sort of you know compromising between
these two and so now you can see as we
as we increase alpha what I've shown
here is is the the red is behavioral
cloning the green is our the result I
showed you before and as we increase
alpha we get closer and closer to the to
the behavioral cloning results so that's
the that's behavioral cloning from
observation the model-based approach
we've also explored a model free
approach called generative adversarial
imitation from observation or guy foe
and and the observation here is these
are some state transitions in the hopper
domain where you basically have a four
dimensional plot here that take two of
the state features where you have the
before and after where which so you
before and after of two different
variables which gives you four different
parameters three of which are plotted on
the axis and one is shown by color and
the the only thing you have to take away
from here is that the the demonstration
data is distribution is very different
than the random policies distribution so
again this motivates the idea that you'd
want to to motivates the idea from
behavioral cloning where you want to try
to relearn the inverse dynamics model
but this also shows that if we can
generate a policy that shows transitions
more like
it'll be closer to the demonstration
right so we're basically trying to
generate a policy that will have state
transitions that look more like the
demonstration state transitions and so
the way we do this it's motivated by one
of these general generative adversarial
methods the demonstrator on the left
there gets state next state transitions
it's learning a discriminator shown in
yellow that classifies all of those as
positive or as one and then on the on
the imitator side we take a state we're
gonna learn this isn't gonna be the
generator learn a policy that outputs an
action which then gets sent into the
environment and paired with the same
state that was sent before and now that
same discriminator from the
demonstration side wants to classify
those as being from the imitator right
so in this in the classic generative
adversarial method the policy is trying
to learn something that will fool the
discriminator and the discriminators
trying to tell the difference between
the demonstration and the imitation and
as you run this this process you get a
policy a generator that's that makes it
very increasingly difficult to tell the
difference between them which means it's
as close as possible to the to the
demonstration and so and so that's the
you know that's the sort of diagrammatic
view of the of the algorithm and now
similarly we can show compared to random
and an expert compared to methods that
that do use the the actions here Gale
the state of the art and and our method
guy foe is doing even without access to
the actions doing almost as well I
should say at this point this was all
with data that's generated from
proprioception so we actually have
access to the to the joint angles really
an imitation from observation is about
about video where the states are not
fully observable and so and so we're
gonna take that we now have taken the
same approach and we're gonna present
some results based on this at each guy
next week that basically does that same
idea but now using video frames right so
basically what's going on here you've
got the at the top you have the
generator
the policy that'sthat's taking now four
frames from a from the video of a of an
agent that's be that you're trying to
control and it's outputting in action
that's the policy that that's being
learned and then the discriminator down
here is trying to distinguish the
actions or the transitions that are
happening between the learned policy and
the demonstration data exactly the same
ideas the the earlier slide but now
sending it through a typical
convolutional neural network stack and
and in this case so that you know the
demonstration now just is really from
pixels so this is the the demonstration
that's being used in the in the hopper
task and the learned policy that comes
out of this is able to get very similar
state transitions and in fact behave
behave quite well and so again we can we
can plot now I still have the random and
the the demonstration or expert data I'm
also showing the the sort of a good
policy learning algorithm trp oh that's
also learning straight from video so
that's in some sense the best that we
would expect to do from learning from
visual observations and and in this case
none of the other competitive competitor
methods even get close whereas guy foe
is doing as we get up to about 10 to 15
trajectories doing as well as TR POS and
again just from state only
demonstrations so this is leading you
know to leads to a bunch of ongoing work
this is again this is the ongoing
dissertation of frost Torabi who's here
on an internship and in this room so if
I've sudden you know further you should
actually you know if I've said anything
wrong you'll you know you can correct me
during the the questions or if you had
anyone asks a difficult question they'll
just defer to him but we are testing
algorithms on more domains we're trying
to adapt this for physical robots not
just in the in the simulator and doing
also the you know there's a connection
here trying to do sim to real transfer
learning in from in this way in a
simulator and seeing if it will combine
with ideas like grounded simulation
learning with the
I'm an objective of is you know trying
to be as good at an imitation learning
is as as humans are this is sort of a
favorite video that they of the people
of babies who've just obviously had way
too much time watching this video but
but somehow have been able to copy it
impressive but yes learning from
demonstration is is you know in its
purest form is simply an just copying
right it's not and especially behavioral
cloning there's not much there's not
really a way to break that in inverse
reinforcement learning what you are
learning is trying to you're you're
starting from or you're inducing a
reward function and then learning a
policy to maximize that reward function
in those cases you can actually get
better policies than the demonstration
in I happen to have a post
we're trying to learn a causal model
here we're just trying to learn behavior
so I'm trying to see like what in this
allows me to learn the right policy it's
actually lets me it would be any related
because I might learn the wrong policy
which says I'm in a $9 and if the left
indicator comes on then I'll turn there
but that's not quite true like well yeah
I see what you say so it's that's yeah I
mean what would cause the what would
cause the left indicator to come on if
it doesn't get turned on by the person
in the first place yeah so I mean yeah
let's take this discussion offline
because I think it is it's subtle it
does get into you know issues of
causality and it's I mean really what's
going on here is just trying to get as
close to the state transitions that are
observed and you know yes it's possible
to to do that in a way that would that
would end up having the the wrong effect
but but you know it's same with the bird
and the people right it's the you know
you can you can get similar behavior if
you're just trying to mimic yes please
soundstage
yeah but you will if I tell you about
what I'm doing when I do it and you'll
be able to do it no it's I know but
point very well point very well taken in
fact that's the subject of some ongoing
research with Scott Niko and Ray Mooney
we just got an NSF grant to exactly
improve learning from human feedback
with natural language input as opposed
to just right so there's there's
different modalities that you can learn
from this is just imitation you can also
learn from positive and negative
feedback a person saying good job or a
bad job
I have research in my lab on the team or
algorithm that Brad Knox inter
introduced that's you know just purely
positive and negative feedback but yes
now adding you know language is a very
rich signal and and there's lots of
different ways in which it could be used
and and so yeah we're embarking down
that path right now
yeah yeah exactly and that it does
you're right it does also have good
connections with safety issues like what
are the guardrails you can put on and
and so it learns in a sandbox or learns
you know in a process control without
making the factory explode or something
like that what are the limitations you
can put on these things so yeah there's
lots of lots of issues here that on
learning with with safety constraints
learning with improving with language
feedback there's you know we're not
we're not at all at the limits of what
can be done in terms of learning from
human interaction oh good I know we're
we're roughly out of time so that's
basically what I wanted to say I you
know this all connects back to to the
research question of what what degree
can autonomous intelligent agents learn
in the presence of teammates and your
adversaries in real-time dynamic domain
especially focusing on reinforcement
learning in robotics in this talk there
are other reinforcement learning if I
had more time I could tell you about
some of our work on curriculum learning
and and some of Matthew's work on deep
reinforcement learning and continuous
action spaces other work on learning
from demonstration but I think you know
in the interest of time I'll skip
through that and also there's some other
work on multi-agent systems that we've
done in my lab I'm especially excited
about the problem of ad hoc team work
right now another paper a ditch guy next
week on on learning in these kinds of
settings which is basically the
challenge of how do you get an agent to
to learn to work with teammates that
it's never seen before like a person
playing a pickup soccer game or a pickup
basketball game or robots in the
disaster rescue scenario everybody
bringing one robot but them immediately
figuring out how to work together and so
this challenge of creating a good team
player we've is now a triple a tie
problem and we've made some some good
progress on that and including and
you're just tying everything back
including in the robot soccer domain
where we don't do now however so new
competitions where people eases the
guarantee that these two bring their own
robots and and put them on a field even
though they've never worked together try
to get them to work together as a team
and so this is just a video of one of
those games and it looks a little less
organized then when one print one you
know group programmed all the robots but
that's the you know that's
Challenge is trying to trying to get
them to to work together with with
unknown teammates and there's a special
issue of a IJ coming up now there was
one of John us there's workshops on this
topic so always happy to talk about that
but let me with that let me let me wrap
up and just you know this is the real
theme of this talk was efficient robot
skill learning I told you about grounded
simulation learning and imitation from
observation and you know a bunch of
different methods I'll be here all day
I'll be more than happy and I think I'm
meeting with many of you if people do
want to stick around I'm happy to take
more questions now but I won't be
insulted if if anybody wants to leave so
thanks for your attention rather than
asking about the body with this match
you want to say something about that
that was like
it
but we haven't we haven't gone to the
point of being able to say how how lost
are we do this yet so we're starting
down that path it's a good question
though yeah because then you're right
like the birds and the people there's an
embodiment mismatch in addition to being
observation if it's it's exactly the
same body it's you know that so that's
just still where we're at right now
basically if there when you have when
you're trying to learn from a
demonstration where you don't have the
same actual immunity body of mismatch
yeah I wasn't sure if there was a
basically if there's parts with the
policy that you're trying to imitate
that you have no hope
yeah so since we're getting towards that
bye
once we start dealing with the the video
you know inputs because now we don't
have direct access to the you know even
to the states they're partially
observable things things like that but
yes I mean in principle these algorithms
will work as long as you have a mapping
between the states of the of the one
body in the states of the other body
you're just gonna try to get as close as
you can to you know that to that mapping
so in fact you know one of the this is
sort of one of the things I skipped over
here is is this was some work of Adam
Adam set up in where he was looking at a
sort of learning from interaction where
we were having a person in a body suit
basically controlling the motion of a
now and using that to sort of you know
seed some skills and to do that we had
to make a mapping between you know the
person's joints and the robot joints
which are not the same and then once you
you know once you do that then you can
try to have the robot figure out well
I'm you know the person's there in this
case the idea was that the person was
gonna learn to get better at controlling
the robot rather than the robot getting
better at imitating the person but and
then once doing that the robot would
capture that skill but yes you have to
have that kind of that kind of mapping
and it's you know they're not always you
know they're not always perfect
they said suppose you're watching a
human demonstration where the human
that's some sort of like I don't know
some sort of full level yeah then your
robot has no hope of accomplishing but
they think it close it might be
counterproductive right
I mean imitation is always fraught with
the idea that you know usually you're
imitating imperfect policy you may learn
to imitate the imperfection of the
ceiling and you know it's theoretically
possible that the extent to which you
you know are incorrect in your imitation
actually improves performance but more
often than not you would expect that you
know you're actually going to reduce
performance and you know and the
invitations could also focus on exactly
the wrong thing so yeah there's no it's
you know it's sort of proceed at your
own risk a little bit but there's you
know it's it's the these these methods
do the the big appeal the big appeal of
them is being able to learn from very
few examples right I mean you know and
they one of our you know in this kind of
paradigm like you can I think the
clearest example was actually Brad Brad
Knox and his tamer work was we used the
game of tetris where you know you can
you can learn to play Tetris using
reinforcement learning with you know
hundreds of games but here we were
learning from just a person saying good
move in bad move so it's flashing green
when it was a good move in red when it
was a bad move and in this case it would
take you know even in the first episode
even the first game it starts to look
much better than random right it's not
just placing placing randomly anymore
and by the third you know by the third
game it starts to look like a really
competent Tetris player as opposed to
after thousands and thousands and so you
know that and then of course what you
really want to do is use the
demonstration to speed up learning and
then use reinforcement learning to
actually learn the parts you you want
and that's been that was part of Brad's
thesis as well so it's really you know
you I think I wouldn't recommend
learning only from demonstration we're
but we're looking at ways to learn from
demonstration as effectively as possible
and then yeah in the long run you want
to mix the two to get the best of both
worlds
what about situations where maybe the
robot is just operating at 60 Hertz when
humans are probably operating so
actually in principle if I mean if we
take time out of it if we're just
looking at the that you know the state
transitions right we don't necessarily
matter what the timescale is it just
says what what state comes after the
next state so a demonstration in these
methods could be at sixty Hertz and and
and the operation could be it you know
at a much slower time scale all it's all
we're really optimizing here is what
comes after the last thing now you could
add into it if you wanted to keep the to
them time aligned that they happen at
the same rate but there's actually no
pressure in anything I've talked about
here to work at the same rate it's just
what state comes after it at whatever
rate you're acting alright so I think in
these in these methods it's actually you
know if what you're trying to do is deal
with things that act at different time
line that's that this is actually a
feature for what we've talked about if
what you're trying to do is make them
work at the same rate then we'd have to
add a different we'd have to sort of add
a different device
we repeat the previous case because
honestly the escapes are be changed I
see so the simulators and the simulators
app are the simulator in the real world
operated the same rate but the actions
operate at different ranges yeah so then
the trend that you're not going to get
the mapping between transitions of the
same of the same action so right then we
would have to have to deal with some
kind of other other way of to bring
those into alignment for you again you
could I mean that the first the first
approach cut approach to that would be
to just say you know I'm gonna take the
the action that lasts 30 frames that
gets me to the as close as possible to
the action that the you know that the
demonstrator got to 30 frames later
right you know sort of take jumps in
that kind of a space but you know who
knows we haven't we haven't tried that
holder
and now I wonder that is like and the
Robert Yogi's the same
oh they're out of time I might have one
I wonder if that's the researchers like
you catch that Apple over day old early
what I'm saying
and during those
so I talking about having having sort of
sort of body language as a way of
grounding what the what the Apple was it
might have been a bunch of them but it's
saying yeah I mean I I haven't done in
my lab we haven't done anything that
combines that but I believe I've see
it's maybe somebody else knows of a
pointer on that I believe I've seen seen
work that has used gesture as a as a
part of a way of grounding what a person
is talking about we've done research in
my lab on gaze I'm using gaze as an
indicator and in fact too you have when
when a robot's passing a person in the
hallway having the robot indicate with a
sort of an a gaze that it's gonna go
this direction but you're looking there
and try to influence the direction the
person goes which is a form of gesture
but we haven't we haven't specifically
used any pointing but I do believe
there's research in this space in the
human robot interaction community
yeah language and gesture and images
it's a sort of multimodal multimodal
kind of interaction or multimodal
learning yeah so we were trying to treat
the the simulator as a black box so it's
it's to change the state transition is
sort of opening up the simulator and
changing the actual simulator by
changing the by putting a wrapper around
the actions the simulator can remain the
same it has its internal transition
function we don't have to know whether
it's using you know matrix
multiplications or or like you but we
just change the input to the simulator
and the state transition isn't something
that we really have control over at the
policy level right the policy is
selecting what action to take it's not
selecting what state transition to make
that's the simulators
[Music]
we incorporate that sort of aggression
yeah you'd also then have to change the
the state of the robot in the simulator
right it would have to tell you you'd
not only be telling the you know so
you'd have to sort of teleport the joint
to where it actually is going so it'd
look a lot more awkward I mean I guess
in principle it could be a mini of a
parallel method to explore but you know
the nice thing about changing the
actions is it really is just a wrapper
to the simulator we don't have to it we
don't have to know anything about it so
the simulator is a black box we just you
know alter the alter the action and then
the simulator does its normal job both
changing the physics of the robot and
telling our policy what the next date is
yeah no I think that's so in in the you
know and this sort of ad-hoc teamwork
work that so that's sort of the
assumption in some sense is that the
agents are all domain experts already in
the domain individually but they haven't
worked together before and so there's a
notion of one of the typical methods for
doing this is to sort of have sort of
some Bank of of types of agents of
teammates and then try to try to say oh
I have experience with the you know the
type of agent that that you know always
shoots the ball from really far and
misses or you know the ones that run a
lot and you know and pass all or
whatever yeah it's a very broad
challenge problem that is designed to
encompass that and the it so there is
some work in that Hawk teamwork that
does say well if you first a lot of it
has assumed that there is no shared
language or no shared communication and
you know the fact is I can go to you
know I can go to China and and and play
a pickup soccer game with people I don't
have any shared verbal language with and
still you know but there has been work
also on on you know if you do have that
language what should you say and when
should you say it and is there you know
both to try to you know to try to
influence what they'll that your
teammates will do but also possibly to
teach your teammates what you're gonna
do in the same like that let you know
the left hand blinker kind of signal is
is something that you know it might be
that every time I'm gonna turn left I'm
gonna turn on the blinker five seconds
beforehand and if my teammates are smart
enough they'll be able to now predict
what I'm gonna do in the future and
therefore improve their plans right so
language and communication can play a
big role in this and it's it's there's a
you know there can be right so so I mean
the whole premise here is that you don't
get to change your teammates so you know
you can change yourself but you have to
be able to deal with the teammates that
don't know how to learn the teammates
that are you know that are really bad
the teammates that are better than you
the teammates that do learn and you're
so a really good team player can adapt
to all of those situations right and and
so number one recognize which type of
teammate am i interacting with right now
and then given that one you know if it's
a learning one yes let me take actions
that will actually help them improve
their performance that make art make our
team shine if I figure out they're not
gonna learn no matter what then that's
just a waste of my time right so you
know the the the premise is and people
went you know when they go into this say
oh let me just change the teammates once
we do that the whole thing becomes easy
but the my you know I always insist in
this that we have to be able to deal
with whatever you know whatever you're
given which is the case in the real
world right you become teammates with
with other people so that's that to me
that's one of the fascinating aspects of
this challenge please
yeah so the the research probably zeroed
in on in that particular paper was
exactly this just the open open world
reasoning with the hypothetical objects
that are that are indicated by language
where you don't know ahead of time
whether they actually exist or not so in
this case the robot knew that fruit was
in the that appeared in the kitchen it
had a knowledge of where were the three
surfaces in the kitchen where the apple
might appear there was there's a pretty
big knowledge base already present and
it had the language capabilities already
given that the thing we zeroed in on
right there was just when you know the
the open world aspect of when a person
says I want an apple from the kitchen
you don't want to to then instantiate an
apple and assume that the apple is
really there for sure because that could
lead to contradictions in your database
down the road you want to maintain this
hypothetical object that's different
from the objects that are in your
database and then be able to deal with
both the situation where you see one and
then you can unify the hypothetical with
the with the true one and make the plan
you know and carry on with your plan or
the case where the the hypothesis was
false so it's it's it's really I mean
the the paper was presented in the I
caps conference the planning the
planning a scheduling conference so it's
really about sort of you know symbolic
symbolic representations and and and
reasoning and reasoning and planning in
that kind of a setting now it's part of
a bigger system which is the whole
RoboCup at home you know where we have
situations where the robot doesn't know
the environment ahead of time like in
the restaurant tasks and where there's
perceptual problems and challenges and
all those kinds of things but we focused
just on that open world reasoning in
that part in that paper
yes so in this case it was going to it
wasn't good so this then gets to the
sort of the gesture issue of like if you
know would there be a way to
disambiguate between it in this case
what it's gonna do is it's going to
ground its gonna the first Apple it does
see it's gonna ground with the
hypothetical one it's not gonna keep
open the hypothesis that there might be
more than one and this is the wrong one
but you know that's you know that's that
would be the next step of or maybe it's
reasoning that you know I just have to
find one that's good enough right yeah
these are the kinds of things that
people all there's a lot of research now
in AI on just you know what can we do
with a neural network and to end and
problems like this like robot soccer
like Robocop at home we're just so far
from being able to just you know throw
in there all Network at the real from
perception to action it requires really
bringing together everything that we've
done in AI over all the years it
leverages you know a lot of the research
that that's been great progress that's
happened envision using and and neural
networks and convolutional neural
networks and things like that but we're
you know I think we have to also bring
in this kind of reasoning and symbols
and and the things that and and you know
probabilistic modeling and all of these
things that are that are I think still
really really important parts of the AI
puzzle and so that's why I like these
application domains it forces us to to
grapple with these with these issues
[Applause]